Traduttore: Peggy Berthier
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno a tutti.
Tocca a me rompere il ghiaccio.
Vi immaginerete che è
un onore ma è anche un onere,
anche perché io ho
certe pressioni qua davanti,
ho già fulminato 15 secondi,
quindi un pochino la vivo male.
Allora, di cosa voglio parlarvi?
Voglio parlarvi di come
l'Università può contribuire
a questo "Tornare a crederci"
che è nella natura dell'evento di oggi.
E ho una tesi, che piano
piano porterò avanti,
che è quella in base alla quale
serve un nuovo punto
di equilibrio, a mio avviso,
tra ciò che cambia,
per effetto della mitica tecnologia,
della mitica società moderna,
e ciò che permane,
per come siamo fatti noi uomini.
È un problema forse di ricerca
di un nuovo punto di equilibrio,
e proverò ad argomentare.
Ho una prospettiva, che simpaticamente
rappresento alla “Piccolo Principe”,
ed è una prospettiva che si lega
a una frase che mi è cara,
sempre tratta evidentemente
dal “Piccolo Principe”:
“Non ereditiamo la terra dai nostri avi:
ce la facciamo prestare dai nostri figli”,
perché io cerco di pensare
il più possibile nella logica dei giovani.
Mi fa piacere che questo
sia un evento costruito dai giovani.
Ho in mente i figli, i nipoti:
questa è la prospettiva
di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Per cominciare vi racconto una storia.
È stata scritta nel 1951 da Asimov,
e la trama è questa qua:
nel 2157, cioè fra 40 anni,
Tommy trova in una soffitta
un vecchio libro
che descrive le caratteristiche
del sistema scolastico del XX secolo.
Con grande sorpresa,
lui e la sua amica Margie scoprono
che in quell'epoca i bambini non erano
istruiti da un insegnante elettronico,
come invece accade loro,
ma si recavano in gruppo
in speciali edifici, le scuole,
per essere coinvolti
in un'istruzione comunitaria,
impartita da insegnanti umani.
Margie è affascinata dall'idea
che si potessero avere insegnanti umani.
La bambina ritorna poi nella stanza sotto,
dove l'insegnante computerizzato
è in attesa di continuare il suo lavoro
sull'addizione delle frazioni proprie.
La storia si conclude
con un nostalgico pensiero
per la scuola del XX secolo,
che dà il titolo al racconto:
“Chissà come si divertivano!”.
Allora io mi son chiesto,
ho fatto una rapida rassegna,
ho chiesto: ma si divertivano?
Mi sembra una domanda da porsi,
ecco: non so se si divertivano.
Si divertono?
Eh, non so se si divertono.
E forse non abbiamo neanche modo
di misurarlo più di tanto.
Però ho cercato di capire
se c'era un invariante,
tra i diversi contesti.
E l’invariante l'ho scoperta
in una frase di Aristotele:
“Tutti gli uomini, per loro natura,
tendono alla conoscenza”.
Quindi noi abbiamo dentro - 50 anni fa,
oggi, e speriamo anche fra 50 anni,
una naturale propensione ad imparare.
Questa è una vocazione,
una sorta, - come dire -
di orientamento di fondo che noi abbiamo.
Lavoriamo su un terreno positivo:
la nostra voglia di imparare.
Però subito dopo ho pensato
al dibattito che abbiamo intorno.
Ho pensato al fatto che, spesso,
scuola e università
sono nell'occhio del ciclone.
Del fatto che hanno rigidità,
che hanno burocrazia,
che faticano a cambiare.
Ho pensato al fatto
che di laureati, in Italia,
ne abbiamo pochi,
e le statistiche ce lo confermano.
Ho pensato a quanto sono pericolosi
i mantra per cui diciamo:
eh, ma le professioni
tra 10-15 anni noi non le conosciamo,
sono ignote a tutti, e poi cosa facciamo?
Ho pensato ai pericoli di quella
che chiamiamo l’information overload,
cioè il fatto che siamo immersi
in montagne di dati e di informazioni
e rischiamo di confondere i dati
e le informazioni con la conoscenza,
[che] son due cose diverse.
Rischiamo di perdere
anche un po' nel linguaggio.
Qualcuno giustamente si pone il problema
se sappiamo ancora
scrivere in italiano oppure no.
Cominciava a diventare tutto
un po' buio, un po' all'italiana,
un po' di ipercritico.
Ho detto: serve un cambio di velocità,
e sono andato a pescarlo
al Festival di Sanremo,
con una caduta di tono
evidentemente tipica mia.
Ho preso Gabbani e ho detto:
però che bello questo
“comunque vada, Panta Rei”,
cioè, comunque vada, tutto scorre.
Quindi noi dobbiamo,
in qualche modo, guardare avanti.
Mettiamo al centro
dell'attenzione l'università.
L'università è l'ambito elettivo
dove si fa ricerca e alta formazione.
Allora: sulla ricerca, poche parole.
Mi son posto il problema della distanza.
Spesso si dice,
l'università è distante
dalle imprese, dalla società civile.
Sono andato a prendere una frase
nel mio campo, del management,
dove si diceva:
“È possibile avere
un professore di management
che non ha mai messo piede
nel business, se non come cliente?”.
Bene, è uno stimolo.
Noi dobbiamo riavviare
una cinghia di trasmissione potente
tra università
e sistema economico sociale.
Qualcosa sta succedendo,
ma qualcosa ancora deve accadere.
Faccio un passo oltre, però,
torno ai sistemi formativi,
cioè quindi al mondo – diciamo -
dell'insegnamento.
Io credo che insegnare
non sia più di tanto
una questione tecnica:
credo che sia, per molti
tra noi, una vocazione.
Non poteva - ecco, la frase che ho citato
veniva da Harvard Business Review,
scusate ho perso questo passaggio,
ma è la fretta che mi stressa,
Veniva dall’Harvard Business Review,
era autorevole ed era datata 2005,
quindi il dibattito c'è da tempo.
Comunque, torno all’insegnare.
Citazione da interista, Severgnini dice:
“Attenzione, un insegnante
è un minatore di talento”.
Questa è la responsabilità che abbiamo.
Io credo altresì, come dicevamo,
che apprendere non sia più di tanto
una questione tecnica.
Ce lo confermava poco fa Aristotele;
ce lo ridice, in altra forma, Plutarco:
“La mente dei nostri studenti
è un fuoco da accendere”.
Io credo che i talenti ci siano,
credo altresì che i fuochi
da accendere ci siano.
Dobbiamo essere positivi,
dobbiamo per forza guardare avanti.
Semmai il tema è la scintilla,
cioè il collegamento tra talenti e fuoco.
Mettiamo al centro dell'attenzione
qual è l'obiettivo di questo mestiere:
è quello di contribuire a costruire
delle personalità, delle identità.
Identità - come dire - culturali,
identità nella società civile,
identità dalla capacità,
attitudini individuali.
Pongo l'attenzione su quello
che credo sia il centro della questione:
oggi si ha sempre più bisogno
di allenare al problem solving,
di immergere i giovani
nel pensiero critico,
di stimolare al lavoro con altre persone,
di – consentitemi - allenare alla fatica,
di trasmettere il senso
del risultato lungo,
non solo del risultato breve.
Direte: “Ma professore, e le competenze?”.
Certo che noi diamo competenze,
ma io credo che oggi l’asse
debba essere spostato di più
sulle cose che vi ho detto prima,
sugli atteggiamenti,
i comportamenti, le attitudini.
Non lo dice Visconti,
lo dicono i recruiters.
Quando li incontriamo, ci dicono:
“Abbiamo sempre più bisogno di giovani
che abbiano quelle caratteristiche”.
Per costruire su quelle caratteristiche
si aprono delle praterie
- uso questa espressione.
C’è la prateria dei modelli didattici:
come si fa didattica?
Io non butterei via
il pennarello con cui sono cresciuto,
ma guarderei con attenzione
anche alle aule multimediali,
alla digitalizzazione delle classi.
C'è un problema di equilibrio.
Io terrei il buono di PowerPoint,
e lo sto usando,
ma starei anche attento
a provocazioni come questa:
“Il pensiero PowerPoint
- il programma che ci rende stupidi”.
C'è un rischio di
omogeneizzazione dei contenuti.
C'è una prateria
– passo a un'altra prateria -
sui modelli di valutazione,
sui metodi di valutazione.
Forse noi abbiamo abbandonato,
in alcuni ambiti evidentemente,
gli esami scritti
- scusate, gli esami orali:
facciamo troppi esami scritti.
Forse siamo prigionieri del pass or fail,
forse stiamo spingendo troppo
sulla valutazione
e abbiamo rallentato sulle motivazioni,
sulla costruzione di quello
che porta alla valutazione.
C'è un'altra enorme prateria
che è la prateria dei modelli
di apprendimento dei giovani.
Io non sono un esperto, però credo che lì
dobbiamo veramente capirci di più.
Noi non possiamo nasconderci
dietro il fatto che loro imparino
si dice “a cassetto”, “a telescopio”,
“a papà Google”, “a Whatsapp”.
Vabbè, sono frasi di circostanza;
ma è evidente che i modelli
di apprendimento dei giovani
sono diversi da quelli
con cui sono cresciuto io.
Allora serve - come dire -
accanto a queste tre dimensioni,
a un certo punto mi son detto,
ci sarebbero altre praterie.
Ma poi c'è la prateria delle praterie,
che è quella su cui ho costruito
un po' questo intervento,
che è: ben venga la rincorsa
al cambiamento, stiamoci dietro!
Facciamo addestramento,
facciamo formazione continua.
Io un pochino anche sento
odor di ideologia e non mi piace,
quindi ben venga il lifelong learning.
Benissimo, perché è questo che gira;
ma stiamo attenti,
che per tornare a crederci
- e forse per continuare a divertirci -
dobbiamo anche tenere
una prospettiva di lunga durata,
quindi non abbandoniamo
i nostri modelli di apprendimento,
quelli che abbiamo sempre avuto,
quelli che un po' ci hanno accompagnato.
Uno dice: “Sì, ma concretamente,
questo long lasting learning che cos'è?”.
Ecco, quello che provo a fare,
che proviamo a fare con i miei colleghi,
con gli studenti eccetera
è fondamentalmente due cose.
Su alcune siamo più avanti,
su qualcun'altra un pochino meno.
Però la prima è insistere
sul valore positivo dell'esperienza.
Io credo che noi dobbiamo dedicare tempo
al fare, al far incontrare esperienze.
Troppe volte mi capita
che qualcuno associ l'esperienza
con la resistenza al cambiamento.
L'esperienza è un grande valore,
si trovano dimensioni di saggezza
in persone che magari
non sono mai state nella Silicon Valley,
o forse, [proprio] perché non ci sono
state hanno una dimensione di saggezza.
Quindi stiamo attenti a legittimare
il fare, l’incontrare,
lo sporcarsi le mani.
La seconda direttrice
è quella di contaminare il più possibile
la cultura scientifica
con la cultura umanistica.
Per anni si è lavorato
un po' a silos, indubbiamente;
concretamente, io ho in mente
- quando riusciremo -
di recuperare un po' di filosofia
nei nostri insegnamenti
- quelli che ho io -
di recuperare un po' di antropologia,
di ridare spazio magari
alla storia economica.
Quindi di costruire,
con un po' di pazienza,
una trasfusione tra la tecnica,
la scienza e le discipline umanistiche.
Chiudo citando De Gregori,
quindi, diciamo, torno ai livelli
da cui sono partito.
“La storia siamo noi” dice lui.
Tocca a noi costruirla
e dobbiamo costruirla oggi, non è tardi.
Qualcuno mi ricorda giustamente
il maestro Manzi, non è tardi;
ma non è neanche presto.
E robabilmente
questa prospettiva culturale
della contaminazione
tra ciò che cambia e ciò che permane
è una bella sfida da seguire.
C'è poi un'altra dimensione,
per tornare a crederci,
che è un invariante, che è il coraggio.
Credo che chi ha fatto questo evento
abbia messo del coraggio,
e questo è molto bello,
la determinazione.
E quindi chiudo citando in dialetto
un mio grande maestro di vita
che mi diceva: “Prufesur, mai mulà”,
cito in italiano: “mai mollare”
e cito, da artista di strada di Londra:
“Never, never give up”.
Grazie.
(Applausi)